artificial intelligence or AI is the
technology behind everything from
self-driving cars to military drones
last week a new documentary premiered
that focuses on both the benefits and
the dangers of AI do you trust this
computer it features interviews with
some of the tech world's greatest minds
including Elon Musk who endorsed the
film via Twitter here's a sample most
people are not aware that what Google is
doing is actually a form of artificial
intelligence they just go there they
type in a thing Google gives them the
answer with each search we train it to
be better
sometimes we type in the search and it
tells us the answer before you finished
asking the question you know who is the
president of Kazakhstan and it'll just
tell you you don't have to go to the
Kazakhstan national website to find out
didn't used to be able to do that that
is artificial intelligence it's one of
these striking contradictions that we're
facing Google and Facebook at all have
built businesses on giving us as a
society free stuff but it's a Faustian
bargain they're extracting something
from us in exchange it does strike right
at the issue of how much we should trust
these machines documentarian Chris Payne
is the film's director and executive
producer Chris good morning thank you
for having me so tell me how did you
come up with this idea to do this doc
you know I got one of those messages
when you plug your smartphone into your
computer it goes do you trust this
computer it's like I don't think I do as
much as I used to right like so it's not
what's let's look at that what's going
on behind the scenes and maybe there's a
cool film in here as you as you started
asking that question and asking it with
some of the brightest people in the in
the in the whole AI sphere did you get
more fearful I kind of did yeah I mean
what scares you the most well you you
kind of assume that tech is gonna roll
out in a way that's just more and more
helpful and I think it really has but
what I realized was that the algorithms
behind so much of the stuff we do every
day are getting to know us better than
we know ourselves yeah and that could
that could begin to work against us you
know when my Indian grandmother came to
American the
she could not understand the answering
machine it just boggled her mind and
sometimes I feel like my Indian
grandmother when we talk about AI I just
don't get where this is going what do
you think the biggest developments are
in AI right now I think the biggest
stuff going on is behind the scenes
stuff the facial recognition the way
they're putting it into military drones
and other kinds of military applications
and then the really great stuff to it in
medicine and in what we go shopping
I mean it's becoming the new electricity
it's behind everything what's
interesting that as you point out though
is it's more than more than countries
it's companies that are leading this
revolution try not yes that's right yeah
the biggest players are Google and
Facebook and IBM I mean certainly the
Chinese are pouring billions of dollars
into this but right here in the states
is we have really some of the best eye
on AI in the world you actually refer to
Google as a Manhattan Project of AI what
did you mean by that well behind the
scenes you know one thing that Google is
doing is they're very interested in
creating very smart machines that can
win games and they have a company
they're called deep mind and deep mind
you know it's waiting more and more
games they I guess they won't go this
year
and how these machines get smarter we
don't know what kinds of games they're
going to end up winning and so it seems
kind of harmless at first but it may be
a long longer term risk for us the
biggest one of the biggest fears that
many people have is ultimately they'll
start taking our jobs how realistic is
that and how pervasive do you think
that's going to become I it's happening
you know I did a show on the New York
Stock Exchange yesterday and I noticed
that there are a lot less people there
than they were almost nobody there I go
bunch of computers together in medicine
and in fact iBM has a job that one day
I'd they won't need me to direct
documentaries I think I think you see it
in blue-collar jobs we know about those
and and also in white color jobs like
first year analytics you know computers
can do a lot of things that lawyers used
to do for the first few days so we're
all we're all threatened by these but
we're also helped yes like a one-way
street it's like just making our job
easier but it's also beginning to take
them away yeah you say that we are
slaves to technology and we're not
returning backs no onward upwards and
onwards Chris pain thank you
much for joining you for having me